hi I'm Alexis and if you know me you
know I love a good bowl of mac and
cheese
I've had many varieties for mac and
cheese over the years and everyone has
their favorite recipe it's really one of
those dishes that is so customizable you
can use different cheeses different
spices different pasta it's really like
choose-your-own-adventure I'm going to
show you my recipes for three minutes
thirty minutes and three hour mac and
cheese so you can make a bowl of mac and
cheese whether you have a few minutes or
a few hours first up we've got a
three-minute mac and cheese it actually
takes a little longer than three minutes
but really fast you can do this in a mug
you could do it in a bowl great for dorm
rooms it's really simple and it's
actually like shockingly good first up
it's going to add my dried pasta along
with some water I'm gonna let the pasta
cook for about two minutes if it needs
more time I'm gonna have another minute
and because it's in a mug it should go
pretty quickly okay so my pasta is about
al dente right now and over here I've
got some pre shredded cheddar cheese
it's good to use pre shredded cheddar
cheese for the microwave because it
actually has some cornstarch already in
it which is gonna help make a creamier
sauce I'm adding a little more to like
really solidify it together you don't
want the cheese to separate salt pepper
slippin Addison cheese and add cheese
and I'll just give that a little stir
from here I'm just gonna put it in for
30 seconds he'll probably take two
intervals make sure the cheese is
melting and nothin
[Music]
it kind of looks like this gloopy mess
but you're gonna give it a stir and do
it put 30 more seconds you're done there
you go
mac and cheese in a month it's actually
crazy how good this is I really stand by
the next two recipes but if you're in a
pinch you're gonna have dinner in under
10 minutes
the second mac and cheese is a stovetop
mac and cheese which is pretty common
it's really easy to do great weeknight
option I'm gonna use a lot of these
orange cheeses to get that classic
all-american mac and cheese for this
version I'm going to hand grate my sharp
cheddar Gouda and I've got Monterey Jack
Monterey Jack doesn't have a lot of
flavor but it's really good for creating
this like we gooey traditional mac and
cheese the next step in our mac and
cheese is making a béchamel which sounds
scary but I promise is super easy
first up take your butter and melt it
you know I think the internet will
probably hate me for this but I have
never eaten kraft mac and cheese people
get really upset when I tell them that
once the butter is melted you're going
to add your flour and this process is
actually called making a roux you're
cooking the flour off for one to two
minutes until it gets lightly golden and
you want to make sure that you
continuously whisk so that the flour
doesn't burn in places
this looks great it's nice and golden
brown you're gonna add your milk and so
once you add the milk then it becomes a
bechamel a roux is the base bechamel is
the sauce and I'm gonna add some ground
mustard paprika pinch of salt and some
pepper I always feel like this part is
putting magical as the bechamel comes
together at first it looks like nothing
it just looks like seasoned milk that as
you keep stirring it'll slowly begin to
thicken and you're gonna cook it for
eight to ten minutes until it can coat
the back of spoon it's gonna look like a
thicker sauce it's bubbling it's thick
now cheese time so adding the Monterey
Jack Gouda and the cheddar
and it's gonna get like super cheesy
I've got some cooked pasta but you want
to make sure that you're doing this at
the same time so that your pasta it's
ready to go as soon as the cheeses and
then give it a stir
that's it stovetop mac and cheese oh so
cheesy I love this mac and cheese
because it comes together in 30 minutes
it's so flavorful it's so gooey gooey
melty like when I think of mac and
cheese this is kind of what I think of
oh it's really my ideal mac and cheese
I've got a long way to go for our next
dish but I'm gonna eat this for lunch
first I'm finally onto the three hour
mac and cheese which is so indulgent
it's so rich really if you have some
time this one's worth making this is the
perfect dish for a holiday for a dinner
party something where you want to put a
little more time and effort into it the
first step to this mac and cheese is
making garlic confit and garlic oil I'm
gonna add my olive oil to a pan and just
warm it through over medium heat next up
garlic so I've got a peel all these
cloves a really easy way to do that you
can take your chef's knife you just want
to do it enough so that the peel is
gonna come easily off of the garlic
clove last clove of garlic my oils
heated and just adding adding the cloves
in and I'm just gonna simmer it for
about 45 to 55 minutes until the garlic
is super tender and the oil is infused
it already smells so good garlic oil
actually stays good for about a month in
the fridge you can use the oil first and
veggies you could use an analogous take
this and do whatever you want with it
we're making liquid gold right here I'm
just gonna let this go and get certain
the next part next up is making homemade
breadcrumbs so loaf of bread and all
you're gonna do is
haier it up you won't do pretty pretty
small pieces look if you have time
making your own breadcrumbs is totally
worth it I will admit that it is
something but I usually don't do myself
but if you don't want to do it you can
use panko or you could use regular
breadcrumbs the sourdough smells so good
it's gonna make great breadcrumbs once
you've got a tray of bread just pop it
in the oven for about 20 minutes 350
just dry it out and get those nice
crispy bits it smells so good in this
room it's like garlic City over here the
garlic is super tender the oils infused
so now I'll take the garlic oil off the
heat and put it through a strainer I'm
gonna let it cool to room temperature
while I work on my breadcrumbs I've got
my toasted breadcrumbs they were in the
oven for about 20 minutes and now
they're nice and dry it out toasty like
that so adding them to a bowl of the
food processor a big guy if you have it
okay so we're ready to blitz I want the
breadcrumbs to be mostly fine with a few
bigger jumps so for this recipe I need
about 2 cups of breadcrumbs so there's
one it's a loose interpretation of
genetics so you can see with these
breadcrumbs that they're mostly fine on
the bottom but then there's some bigger
pieces up top I personally like the
uneven texture but you can make them
more fine at home if you want to I've
got some Parmesan cheese here and then
I've got that garlic oil that was
infused parmesan garlic bread crumbs
what is better than that so my
breadcrumbs are done I'm gonna reserve
this until we're ready to bake the mac
and cheese the last step for my 3-hour
mac and cheese is making a béchamel once
more again at the butter so it's the
same process as soon as the butter is
melted you can add the flour I want to
get it to be golden brown have a nice
nutty flavor so my roux is ready now
it's time to add the milk and the rest
of the seasoning I'm gonna add a big
pinch of salt black pepper
some nutmeg and a little time you might
think of nutmeg as typically a sweeter
spice or something used in desserts but
it's actually used in a lot of sauces
and again we've got that Cayenne to also
add some heat
so my sauce is really thick and creamy
now at the cheese I've got white cheddar
I've got Greer and I've got fontina
which doesn't have a lot of flavor but
again it's super melty and it's gonna
make this like cheese pull city
population oven mac and cheese okay I've
got some precooked cavatappi here and oh
my god one more addition I mashed up
some of the garlic confit and I'm gonna
add it to the pasta with the cheese so I
did about three cloves which gives the
flavor of garlic without being
overpowering if you're a garlic fanatic
by all means add more so I've got my
buttered baking dish here and I'm just
gonna add the pasta so just Pat it in an
even layer and now we've got my garlicky
parmesan bread crumbs and just put them
in an even layer I grew up with mac and
cheese that was done in the oven so to
me this is the most nostalgic recipe I
like my bread crumbs to be a bit uneven
so I've got some bigger pieces some
smaller pieces I also like some of the
mac and cheese to like poke out and get
a little brown anyway
this is ready to bake gonna bake this
for about 50 minutes until it turns
golden brown and we're ready to eat I've
got my beautiful baked mac and cheese it
smells so good and I think I'm gonna fry
it mmm the breadcrumbs are so crunchy oh
my god
it's like just lightly perfumed with
garlic
no crunch and there you have it a three
minute 30 minute and 3-hour mac and
cheese whether it's Thanksgiving or
dinner at the dorms you should always
have time to make a great bowl of mac
and cheese let me know in the comments
which one your favorite is I'm gonna
take this home and eat on my couch
tonight
so with that goodnight
[Music]
[Music]